wir haben alle sie gefragt was sie
eigentlich zu diesem krieg sagen was sie
über diesen krieg denken und auch ob sie
angst haben und wir schauen mal auf das
was wir uns geantwortet haben auf die
frage ob sie angst haben dass russland
weitere länder an greift ja da sagt die
deutliche mehrheit der von 76 prozent
der befragten dass sie aktuell darüber
besorgt ist dass russische truppen auch
weitere länder als die ukraine angreifen
könnten etwa ein fünftel der befragten
ist diesbezüglich aktuell unbesorgt und
5 prozent geben an ist nicht wissen zu
wollen oder keine angabe machen zu
wollen wir haben auch gefragt ob sie
besorgt sind dass atomwaffen eingesetzt
werden könnten da sagt die deutliche
mehrheit von 77 prozent ja sie sind
besorgt dass auch atomwaffen eingesetzt
werden könnten etwa ein fünftel ist
hinsichtlich dieses einsetzt ist
unbesorgt 5 prozent geben an dass sie es
nicht wissen wir haben wir haben auch
noch gefragt glauben sie dass sich
deutschland im falle eines militärischen
angriffs russland verteidigen könnte tja
diese antwort ist auch sehr deutlich 7
und 67 prozent der befragten glauben
nämlich nicht dass wir in der lage sind
im falle eines angriffs uns anständig zu
verteidigen nur 23 prozent der befragten
glauben dass deutschland in der lage
dazu ist
tja und sollte deutschland jetzt seine
gasimporte aus russland endlich stoppen
da sagt die absolute mehrheit von 60
prozent der befragten ja das sollten wir
tun 28 prozent sind dagegen zwölf
prozent sagen sie machen keine angabe
dazu noch eine frage gab es auch zur
wehrpflicht in deutschland da gibt es
jetzt auch heftige diskussionen darüber
ob die wieder eingeführt werden sollte
die meisten befragten sprechen sich
dafür aus sie wollen dass die
wehrpflicht zurückkommt 48 zu 38 prozent
14 prozent der befragten geben an da
möchte ich keine angabe zu machen das
sind natürlich zahlen die wir besprechen
wollen bei uns im studio bild live chef
claus strunz schönen guten morgen klaus
also 76 haben jetzt tatsächlich angst
davor dass auch andere länder
angegriffen werden könnten was ist deine
meinung dazu also all die zahlen die wir
gesehen haben spektakuläre zahlen oder
einer umfrage für bild am sonntag
zeigen ja dass
politik eben immer auch eine sache der
emotionen ist und nicht des verstandes
denn alles was die menschen jetzt sagen
galt auch schon vor zwei jahren also wir
waren nicht richtig aufgestellt wir
haben keine panzer die funktionieren wir
haben u boote die nicht wieder
auftauchen wir haben irgendwie flieger
die nicht starten können oder schnell
wieder gewartet werden müssen wir haben
auf das falsche energie prinzip gesetzt
und uns damit total abhängig gemacht
also alles was hier jetzt aufscheint ist
nicht neu die leute haben aber sozusagen
aus der emotion heraus immer entschieden
der putin der will doch nur spielen das
ist ihnen von der politik auch ein
gesungen worden eingelullt waren sie
waren wir alle die haben gedacht ja also
diese atomkraft wenn da mal was passiert
ist ja so schrecklich aber natürlich ist
die versorgungssicherheit und das alles
wird jetzt klar insofern sind diese
zahlen richtungsweisend und im prinzip
so was um im vokabular dieser tage zu
bleiben der marschbefehl für unsere
regierung wie sie umsteuern muss was sie
zum teil begonnen hat aber wo sie eben
auch geschwindigkeit aufnehmen
marschbefehl für einen nato-einsatz ist
es definitiv nicht denn die leute haben
angst auch vor einem atomkrieg teils
leser ja also ich glaube es ist auch
eine bestätigung für olaf scholz und und
dieses klaren nein zum militärischen
intervenieren da olaf scholz ja wenn ich
es richtig sehe der bundeskanzler aller
deutschen ist ist das ein
ernstzunehmendes votum also all
diejenigen die das anders sehen und wir
und ich habe ja auch sozusagen das
gefühl wir müssen mehr tun müssen dieses
mehr tun aber definieren als mehr waffen
liefern mehr
hilfspakete schnüren mehr in die
kommunikation einhegen aber auf keinen
fall militärische maßnahmen denn dafür
haben die menschen angst und olaf scholz
ist den deutschen bürgern verpflichtet
die wollen nicht dass die nato
militärisch eingreift aus angst
überfallen zu werden und aus angst dass
wir uns auch gar nicht nach gegen werden
können wegen des desolaten zustandes der
bundeswehr mir tatsächlich auch sorgen
jetzt soll ja nun ordentlich investiert
worden aber das kommt reichlich spät
wichtig glaube ich ist also 100
milliarden ist ja schon mal was nicht
wenig wie kann man halt auch falsch
ausgegeben oder zu langsam und in sachen
die man dann doch nicht brauchten
veraltete technologie daher die
verteidigungsministerin unter
bundeskanzler jetzt wirklich wichtige
entscheidungen zu treffen ich glaube
aber das entscheidende liegt woanders
ich glaube die wehrpflicht muss
zurückkommen die wehrpflicht war ja eben
nicht jetzt muss man zum bund und dann
sondern die wehrpflicht war sich
verteidigen können bis hinein in jede
familie präsenz in der gesellschaft als
ich bei der bundeswehr war immer der
große slogan bürger in uniform also
bürger der eintritt für freiheit für
recht für für rechtssicherheit für alles
was uns in unserem system wichtig ist
der dann aber auch sagt dazu bin ich
bereit oder dafür bin ich bereit ist zu
verteidigen denn dieses symbolik in der
mitte der gesellschaft die armee in der
mitte der gesellschaft wieder zu
verankern und ich merke richtig wie alle
zusammen zum opa die armee gehört doch
nicht in die mitte der gesellschaft das
sind ja schlimme leute die am liebsten
schießen und alles andere leute tot
schießen nein die armee gehört in die
mitte der gesellschaft weil der
grundwert sich verteidigen zu können
jetzt deutlich geworden ist es ist
eigentlich nicht eine schande dass die
armee nicht längst in der mitte der
gesellschaft ist wenn man sich andere
länder anguckt zum beispiel die usa die
verehren ihre soldaten wir haben da
historisch irgendwie ein problem wobei
die dabei kann dann kann man vielleicht
sagen sie verehren sie ein stück zurück
das war das extremste nach vietnam und
sonst wo hin und lasse sie dort elendig
kopieren aber ja die werte dort man dort
ist die wertschätzung in der
gesellschaft größer also ich würde sagen
wenn wenn man im zug fährt und es kommt
ein soldat den sitzplatz sucht steht man
auf und sagt vielen dank dass sie unsere
freiheit verteidigen ist in deutschland
da der bundeswehr denkt war das würde
ich immer tun wahrscheinlich würde er
ablehnen was die jünger ist als ich aber
es sollte ja auch noch höflich
unhöfliche soldaten gibt ich mach das
bewusst so ein bisschen ironisch weil
ich die letzten 20 jahre erlebt habt die
dann zu dieser absurdität führten die
wehrpflicht abzuschaffen und uns im
grunde schutzlos auszuliefern in einer
welt wo wir uns eingeredet haben wer
soll uns denn sagen reifen dann kam die
pandemie dazwischen das haben wir auch
schon nicht erwartet ohne pandemie woher
soll denn kommen und jetzt plötzlich ist
in unserer unmittelbaren nähe ein
aggressor ein unkalkulierbares ich
übrigens see aus den zahlen auch die
angst der menschen dass der irre ist
absolut dass man eben nicht auf ratio
ratio setzen kann und was macht man denn
mitten im irren der mit einem schwert
auf 1 zu läuft wenn man selber sozusagen
nur eine weiße fahne hat dann wird man
wahrscheinlich schlecht aussehen und das
ist das was die menschen umtreibt und
ich finde insofern diese umfrage einen
wendepunkt auch in der aufstellung und
dem selbstverständnis der bürger in
dieser republik und ich bin froh dass es
jetzt kommt und bin traurig dass es erst
unter der bedrohung kommt das ist quasi
des bahnschranken phänomen also alle
leute sagen immer oder ist ein
unbeschrankte bahnübergang können dann
nicht mehr kinder überfahren werden und
dann tagen gremien statt rente
verwaltungsräte dann ist kein geld da
und dass man erst nach den ersten toten
kind ist am nächsten tag die
bahnschranke da und nach diesem prinzip
funktioniert jetzt auch unsere
verteidigungspolitik immerhin
eine frage habe ich noch es geht um die
gasimporte da haben die deutschen jetzt
gesagt ja die sollten wir stoppen können
wir uns das eigentlich leisten nein wir
können es uns jetzt nicht leisten das
ist ja diese bittere ironie dass wir
quasi den mann der uns unsere freiheit
bedroht und die ukraine umbringt
massenhaft jeden tag millionen um
millionen und millionen rüberschieben
das geht gar nicht anders weil sonst ich
sag jetzt mal im übertragenden sinne
hier die lichter ausgehen er die
gasheizungen aber
versteht was ich meine ich glaube es ist
jetzt der umgekehrte fukushima moment in
fukushima wo am anderen ende der welt in
atomkraftwerk explodiert ist war sofort
die halbe gans wirklich wir müssen uns
um steuern wir müssen raus aus dieser
atomenergie haben eine noch jemanden der
seile hat angela merkel eine
grundüberzeugung der deutschen politik
auf den kopf gestellt nämlich keine
keine atomkraft statt auf atomkraft zu
setzen und ich erwarte dass jetzt der
russland schock der ukraine schock das
umgekehrte fukushima auslöst mit genauso
großer geschwindigkeit müsste man
beschließen nein die atomkraftwerke
abgeschaltet werden sollen ende des
jahres laufen weiter und um ganz ehrlich
zu sein wir investieren sogar neue klaus
dankeschön
wir haben auch sie auf der straße mal
gefragt was halten sie eigentlich von
diesem krieg glauben sie dass
deutschland bei einem russischen angriff
gut aufgestellt wäre schauen auf die
antworten nein allein als deutschland
nicht aber wie gesagt wozu haben wir die
nato wozu sind wir europa und auch da
gemeinsam zu stärken auch militärisch zu
stärken muss man da schon was machen das
sehe ich auch so ich glaube es bringt
nichts weil deutschland hat eigentlich
glaube ich schon genug soldaten ich
glaube es ungefähr 200.000 das reicht
sondern landesverteidigung und wenn es
wirklich akut werden würde die lage dann
käme die viel zu spät das kann man schon
ein bisschen was tun um die bundeswehr
wenigstens auf so einen stand zu bringen
wie sie immer von time warner wenn ich
dass deutschland gut genug aufgestellt
aber ich habe hoffnung dass die usa dann
ihren pflichten nachkommen und uns
gegebenenfalls unterstützen würden
und was haltet ihr gerade von den
sanktionen gegen russland die laufen
sind die gut genug oder müssen wir da
noch härter durchgreifen was kann man
tun ja ich glaube es ist die einzige
möglichkeit den krieg ohne waffen zu
führen und dieser krieg ist ja einfach
da also das ist natürlich hart für die
zivilbevölkerung und kann natürlich auch
nicht dauerhaft zu weiter gehen also ich
finde wir könnten mehr tun ehrlich
gesagt sogar noch also man müsste
eigentlich alles sanktionieren meiner
meinung nach muss jetzt erst mal ich
würde erstmal sagen
keine lange zeit auch mal kurzfristig
vorsicht ansonsten muss man noch mal
nachlegen ja also im moment bin ich
erstaunt überhaupt was die regierung
jetzt alles schon festgelegt hat das
finde ich schon im moment als
ausreichend eigentlich auch als total
positiv und man muss jetzt auch ein
bisschen abwarten wie sich alle dinge so
entwickeln mehr würde ich im moment
nicht machen da nicht nur als deutsche
sondern gesamteuropa müsste danach
liegen und zwar viel größer nach liegen
man kann immer mehr tun glaube ich vor
allem aber die russen im land müssten
mehr tun ich sage jetzt mal abwarten
erst mal abwarten was passiert und
also vielleicht sollten sie noch ein
bisschen lauter werden ja aber sie sind
berechtigt kennen die wände sogar noch
etwas intensiver ausfallen ich glaube
moment wird alles getan was erforderlich
ist